how optimistic are you on the future of
uh america you talked about america
earlier where you said
americans have a tendency of believing
that's going to be the greatest country
in the world and you know
currency no one can go up against the
currencies the best currency in the
world
how optimistic are you with america as a
product not not crypto not bitcoin
yeah so i believe that america and the
american ideals
are have created and still is the
greatest country in the world
right and the belief in capitalism free
markets and democracy
uh we are very spoiled here in this
country
uh compared to where most people live uh
in the world
uh with that said uh i always look at it
as
just because you were able to ascend to
this position of uh
of privilege and power and and kind of
freedom does not mean that is guaranteed
in the future
and so in the united states i think that
what we are starting to get to a point
of
is we're the fat cat in the room right
we're happy
this is america we can do no wrong we've
got the greatest military in the world
we've got the global reserve currency
we are the kings of the world well every
dynasty
and empire in history has fallen and
usually it is because they become the
fat cat in the room
they stop pursuing innovation they stop
pursuing kind of independent thought and
problem solving and critical thinking
and they simply start saying we win
because we are america
right and i think it's a very dangerous
place to be in and so i think that the
the best place frankly that this is
showing up
is in something like bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies where when you look at
an
open decentralized system you can see
the rhetoric that's being used in a lot
of this people are starting to say
oh some one of our adversaries may use
this technology
and that will be detrimental to the
united states well when you're the
incumbent
you constantly look at regulation and
you look at how can i rig the market to
my advantage how do i king make right
when you're the startup that's not what
you think you think give me the tools
and i'll compete in the free market
you you enjoy the competition right you
want to go fight the battle
and so i think that what we've got to do
is we've got to get back to that right
the industrial revolution and a lot of
what made america america
was about us saying give us the
technology and we're going to go compete
in a free market and we're going to win
and so i think that what ends up
happening is we've got a decision to
make
we're we are the greatest country in the
world do we want to continue to do that
or are we going to go into decline
and i think that what we have to do is
we have to continue to pursue
technological innovation
and we have to make sure that through
incentives whether that's tax
regulation or otherwise that we want the
smartest people in the world
living here working here building here
and employing people
and if we do that we got a shot no
guarantee but we got a shot
but i think there's a couple of other
countries that are starting to catch on
to the game right singapore
uh is one area there's plenty of others
that start saying look we're going to
take the american playbook and we're
going to use it against them
so let's go compete yeah it's going to
be interesting and by the way china
right now i don't know if you saw what
came out story this week
when they said china looks at us as
their equal they no longer look at their
superior this was said this monday
we talked about on the podcast and you
heard peter thiel i think last week i
think it was last week when he talked
about the fact that hey you know china's
using
bitcoin as a way to manipulate the u.s
currency the fiat currency this is the
national security
so what do you think about what peter
thiel is saying because you
when you talk about the startup hey just
20 years ago china was number eight
you know china was number seven and they
did that uh uh olympics and oh wait i
think it was when we're like what the
hell would
the way they would walk how many times
did these guys is the greatest opening
show ever like these guys are
going to compete they went from eight
seven six
five four three two in 2025 they're
planning on being number one
what do you think peter thiel is saying
the fact that they're gonna use
bitcoin to manipulate the u.s currency
to weaken it yeah so i think that
uh the context of his comments are
really important right so first
is uh he was very clear that he's pro
bitcoin he's pro crypto he considers
himself a bitcoin maximalist
uh and uh and believes that it will
continue to accrue value as this like
global store of value
the second thing is that right before he
talked about bitcoin he actually said
that uh
at one point the euro was seen as a
financial weapon by china against the
united states
and it ended up not actually being able
to kind of weaken the dollar enough or
have the impact that they wanted it to
have right so this is not a new concept
or a new framework for people to kind of
evaluate
china's global aspirations compared to
the us uh and so the idea with bitcoin
is that
uh if people start to adopt bitcoin then
that will destabilize the global
uh reserve currency right and bitcoin
will end up being
uh kind of a global reserve currency now
what i always say is bitcoin is a
open network it's an open decentralized
network very similar to the internet
and so when the internet came along the
united states had a very big hand in
creating that and adopting it and
embracing it using it to their advantage
but there are countries around the world
that said oh my god other people are
going to use this
and so we're not going to use it we're
going to cut our citizens off from the
internet north korea is a great example
it didn't turn out so hot for north
korea and their citizens
and so when you have an open
decentralized network naturally people
around the world are going to use it
open systems beat closed systems and so
when you think of it from that
standpoint the united states has a
choice
we can be adversarial and we can be kind
of closed system minded right we could
say hey we're not going to use this
thing because another country may try to
adopt it or use it and and use it to
their benefit
or we can simply say you know what
there's a global game
we're going to go compete we're going to
embrace this and we're going to make
sure that if anyone benefits from
bitcoin in this open system
we benefit more than anybody else and i
think that's the winning strategy here
is it's not to say
oh let's ban our our citizens from using
this let's try to look at this as a
threat
it's to say hey there's a weapon up for
grab let's go use it and we'll be the
winners
because every other country is going to
do that as well so why don't you just go
make sure you benefit more than
everybody else
so if you like this sort of shortcut
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye